all right today I was fortunate enough
to witness the bravery the courage the
might of the US military firsthand as I
traveled with our first lady Melania
Trump to Joint Base Anacostia and Joint
Base langley-eustis where I had the
opportunity to sit down with our first
lady
take a look stay true to myself you use
that term a lot now what do you expand
on that what does that mean considering
and I'll ask you about your roots a
little bit but that stuck out to me I I
do what I think it's right I know I will
get the criticism from the public or
from the media but I will do what is
right and but I feel it's right for the
country and for the people and that's
what I say I want to stay true to myself
and listen myself and what to do and
what is right what is wrong and live
meaningful life every day we're gonna
have that full interview in just a few
minutes along with our highlights of an
incredible trip where do you see these
planes landing and taking off it's
unbelievable first we do have updates on
the muller partisan witch hunt today
Michael Cohen he was sentenced to three
years in prison after he pled guilty to
tax evasion making false statements on a
bank loan application line at Congress
about building a building project that
never even got off the ground and a
questionable campaign finance violation
notice something missing no Trump Russia
collusion none again it's also important
to know Michael Cohen does not have a
cooperation agreement with federal
prosecutors and meanwhile tonight
another top target of this Muller
witch-hunt Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn is asking a federal judge for
leniency and no jail time he pleaded
guilty to lying to investigators but
only after legal bills wrecked his
family finances forced this man 33-year
veteran five years of combat to have to
sell his home and probably was most
likely threatening punitive action
against his son and his business partner
he fell on the sword like probably 99%
of fathers would do and tonight we are
learning some disgusting new details
surrounding how Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn was treated by top federal
of fish
now according to Flynn's sentencing
request then deputy FBI director Andrew
McCabe pressured then national security
adviser Flynn not to have a lawyer
present during a seemingly relaxed Oh
casual meeting with the FBI the one that
they said he lied at except nobody
believed he lied
Flynn agreed to sit down without
attorneys present and was then
subsequently charged with lying during
that very meeting now keep in mind
Andrew McCabe was ultimately fired from
the FBI for him lying to the bureau and
he is currently facing no charges
according to Fox news.com Flynn's filing
also seemingly demonstrates that the FBI
took a significantly more aggressive
tack and handling the Flynn interview
than it did during other similar matters
for example quote no one interviewed
during the FBI's Clinton email
investigation was hit with false
statement charges though investigators
believed those witnesses were untruthful
big difference and so II as we now know
that is called the two-tiered justice
system and by the way this might be part
of the worst part of Flynn's political
persecution the agents interviewing
Flynn they never thought he lied that is
a a such a miscarriage of justice and an
abuse of power corruption scandal one of
the biggest in American history
as we've been telling you and of course
you're not likely to hear about any of
this on any other media especially over
a conspiracy TV MSNBC especially not on
the liberal Morning Joe show where the
host literally spent hours every single
day trying to outdo themselves you know
trading insults about Donald Trump and
the Trump family and anybody associated
with Trump now it's a pretty sad and
scary way to start your morning but
today co-host Mika Brzezinski went too
far is this pretty disgusting slur just
before 9:00 a.m.
take a look understand that Donald Trump
doesn't care Heilemann makes a good
point he doesn't care but why doesn't
Mike Pompeo
right now are the pathetic deflections
that we just heard when he appeared on
Fox and Friends is that a patriot
speaking or a wannabe dictators but boy
dead serious I'm asking are these the
words of a patriot Wow questioning is
patriotism unbelievable over the top and
then following the show on the other
part of the issue and she issued an
apology on Twitter about our language
some bad choice of words I should have
said waterboy like four football teams
or something like that yeah make a
pretty bad choice of words but we're
consistent on this program we don't call
for boycotts we don't call for firings
of any kind in fact when Micah's
colleague MSNBC host joy read when she
was in hot water over homophobic and
conspiracy filled blog that she had we
never called for her to be fired or for
her show to be boycotted people do make
mistakes people are not perfect and I
think we're all human and I don't
believe anybody's career and my honest
opinion should be ruined over a stupid
mistake by the way she's no fan of mine
and neither is liberal Jo and I doubt
they would do this for any opinion host
here of Fox News but it's sad to see
Trump derangement syndrome claim yet
another victim and of course there were
many warning signs as the anti-trump
vitriol got worse and worse and worse
let's take a look it is clear the
president is stunningly ignorant
probably the most ignorant president we
will ever physik nur n't he's warped
he's obsessed with money and sex and he
finds his power through those two things
he will be forever remembered as the
president who traumatized little
children that's his brand now he's the
president who purposefully traumatized
babies and children's very almost
cavemen like it really is like Fred
Flintstone running the country I don't
think he has the moral compass to make a
decision based on our own national
security to anybody who works inside the
White House works on the national
security team works in the State
Department at some point you are working
for a president who is not fit
lead who's gonna do something crazy in
five minutes one hour tonight or
tomorrow like what more do you need to
hear from him to start thinking 25th
amendment or something else we will have
more on this later in the show but first
we need to turn to breaking news in
France widespread manhunt underway for
the gunman in Tuesday's terror attack at
a French Christmas market that left at
least two dead now the 29 year old
suspect identified right there as Sharif
shaked allegedly shouting Allahu Akbar
as he opened fire before escaping from
the scene in a taxi we're also learning
tonight he had a long criminal record
and he was already on the authorities
radar for connections to radical Islam
so far five other people with alleged
ties to the suspect have now been
detained and even more frightening is
that French authorities admit that he
may have already slipped across the
border into Germany we'll keep you
updated we'll pray for the victims scary
times make no mistakes attack like like
this all these attacks underscore the
need for safety and security like places
o at our southern border where we have
caught people with terrorist ties trying
to get into this country where tonight
migrant groups are literally you know
the ones women and children that the
media kept telling us about remember
they were trying to march to the US
consulate over Tijuana demanding
President Trump
either let them into the country or now
they want us to pay them fifty thousand
dollars in reparations to go home pay
you to go home so you don't break our
laws and don't disrespect our
sovereignty
one group organizer arguing that it may
seem like a lot of money to you but it's
a small sum compared to everything the
United States has stolen from Honduras
now look we all know probably the vast
majority of people that come from poor
countries with no opportunity no hope
for their children and grandchildren are
good people searching for a better life
but demanding entry or pay you will
overwhelm your immigration system
there's no way to act to demonstrate
merit to come into this country it's
also a massive security risk as the San
Diego Tribune is reporting thousands of
migrants are now unaccounted for writing
quote in the group of
unaccounted migrants about 3500 are
presumed to have either crossed
illegally into the US moved to other
Mexican border cities or simply fallen
through the cracks that is why the
president is standing firm rightly so on
the border wall forging ahead on keeping
his promise to the Forgotten men and
women of this country to preserve our
nation's safety and security first
remember a wall will literally help
people on both sides be safer and then
of course the wall will have a big door
and you can come in legally as the
president has said but we do have the
right to vet anyone that wants to come
into this country because keeping out
potential terrorists human traffickers
drug traffickers violent cartel members
is a huge number-one priority for our
national security